new moon has a lot more CGI it's got
werewolves more werewolf stuff the first
one didn't have any wearable stuff a lot
of phasing from humans and the
werewolves i think is really cool I'm
not a werewolf on vampires so it's but
I've seen them do it it's a lot of green
screen stuff it's a lot more imagination
it takes thankfully of with the vampire
stuff it's mainly all makeup so I don't
have to do too much for you screw the
makeup they roll this around in flour
for about an hour I mean they put
contact lenses in and then they say go
no through except it's it's airbrush I
think the first time we did was like a
weird Japanese airbrush system that was
an ionizer which was really weird
because if they touched you all they
were doing it gave you a shock so it's
five o'clock in the morning you've been
getting like it's like if you put your
tongue on a battery you get that kind of
shock so so it would wake us up and then
on the second when they kind of Nick's
those who just went with regular makeup
they wanted to tone it down a little bit
it's a classic timeless tale it's Romeo
and Juliet set in the vampire worlds and
vampire mythology it's uh it's been
around for a long time when people like
it so when you mix that with this
timeless tale Romeo and Juliet as for
good times oh my bookie supposed to be
23 so here's my daughter
and I'm telling right now just talking
to my microphone first one the
difference between new moon and twilight
is i think we were more prepared and you
know what it was we know what the town
was going to be the first one we didn't
really know what the tome is going to be
a dynamic set up but I think I'm more
prepared in terms of on the second one
the werewolves have a lot more green
screen stuff our family's up now but in
the third 1 i'm sure we're going to need
a lot of grants that's going to be weird
to play fight airless BS you just have
ocean do you see that it was just you
see how good I did that answer head it
like screw it says she got scared there
was a huge bat they're gonna add that in
later I just hope as a bit by following
four years in row grown up so it's
exciting to play one in real life and as
an actor this isn't wirework and it's
all fun stuff I mean that we get paid to
do fun things
you